liquefied natural gas is to provide
Europe's energy Security in the coming
winter amid the war in Ukraine Russia
isn't delivering the gas it used to and
trying to make itself independent from
Putin's fossil fuel deliveries EU
countries have been buying a lot of LNG
from the Middle East or the United
States at times outbidding countries
that are also heavily banking on
liquefied natural gas like India
Pakistan or Myanmar but now there are
more than 35 LNG Latin vessels drifting
off
the coast of Spain and around the
Mediterranean Spain has six terminals in
total and has around half the
re-gasification capacities of the entire
European union now Spain's national gas
grid operator already said that it may
have to reject on loads of LNG due to
over capacity at its terminals
well for more on this let's bring in
James waddle he's a senior gas Analyst
at the consultancy group energy aspects
welcome to DW James so as there seemed
to be uh you know a over capacity at
these terminals in Spain has Europe
bitten off more than it can chew when
going around the world and buying all
this Natural Gas
but what we're trying to do in Europe is
to make a pipeline grid that was
designed to function from the East to
the West function in Reverse effectively
historically we always used to get lots
of Russian guests coming in uh from the
East and filtering through uh Germany
into Western Europe and that's was the
source of our gas supply since we've had
this shortfall of Russian gas we've been
uh basically pushing the gas hubs high
enough that those are the highest value
markets in the world and that has been
attracting lots of energy Cargoes to
come in and offload but the pipeline
congestion within Europe going from west
to east is just such to the extent that
we have to basically put uh you know LNG
on the on the as floating storage
outside of these terminals
um waiting for a moment when they can
actually unload into the pipeline grid
and send it further east and we have
constraints on both the Spanish border
Northbound into France we have
constraints on the French border into
Germany me which limit that ability to
absorb that uh LNG and at the same time
also we've been very successful in
filling our storage and as you fill up
European storage what happens is you've
got less injection capacity
um as you approach full and so that
means that there isn't that space to put
a lot of the gas and it's not until we
get into the proper heating season in
November December January that will
start to be able to absorb more of this
gas and uh and actually bring it into
the grid James How likely is it that
these vessels will go and take this LNG
to other countries around the world the
demand is there
well right now the price is signaling a
huge contango meaning very low prompt
prices and then uh much higher prices
further uh further on for winter
delivery in Europe so a lot of it is
going to stay you know as floating
storage where you know you're just going
to wait for a month the cost of waiting
for a month is about five dollars mmbtu
and the spread between
um the the prompt contracts and those
for delivery in November December is
about 20. so there's still an economic
rationale just to keep those LNG uh
supplies on tankers outside of Europe
but yes we are starting to see new
buying interest from uh some of the
countries you mentioned at the start
there you know India and um and
potentially some of the other markets in
in Asia coming back into the market four
spot Cargoes because it is uh now
competitive for bidding that those
Cargoes away so uh James in in brief for
producers of LNG it actually pays to
have these vessels sitting outside
outside the port waiting for higher
prices
well we've had a huge explosion in the
cost of actually chartering a vessel so
those those costs are actually holding
LNG on vessels for 30 days or 60 days
are very high historically but the
spreads between prices right now and
prices for delivery in one or two months
are so big right now that it actually
does make economic sense just to keep
the LNG sitting outside of Europe James
waddle uh the consultancy group energy
aspects James thank you for your
thoughts